hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play dumpy the
elephant I got my hands on an oculus
rift thanks to my friend James over here
there's a couple guys over here in the
background just to laugh at me go
absolutely insane with the oculus rift
so this should be pretty funny to watch
so give me a second while I put this on
cuz I can't oh okay
where did I put the headset there's but
it's a little finicky here and once I
got this on I played with it just for a
little bit oh that's it stuff oh I think
it's a little off-center because this is
where dumpee is oh well whatever I'll
deal with it hello yay wait is it gonna
adjust to a point where I'm gonna be
free yeah there we go alright that's
much better
whoa whoa so I'm playing as dumpy the
elephant and I'm just swinging my trunk
of destruction here it's it's so weird I
was living with it just a little bit
before having the time of rubbish
playtime's over kitties where are they
running from you running from
dumpy-dumpy is gonna have fun with you
okay sorry I'm probably being way too
loud but I've kind of forgotten that I'm
in my hotel room right now I mean this
magical Oh so realistic land of Wonders
with these little kids hearing a little
kid ping unuq wait no no oh yeah don't
run away from dummy all right fine you
ran away good me pardon me
woah oh my doing this oh holy crap that
was amazing I know it's just like this
simply oh my god he died that poor kid
Robert don't we don't care don't B's
gonna have the time of dumpees lie
excuse me is that a lemonade stand I'll
avoid it no I hit it anyway sorry I'm
that can spat what what just happened
this little kitty run what whoa what the
hell where did you come from you back up
there buddy okay so shut up your eye
from Toby don't we doesn't want any I'm
like dripping out him okay
this would be bad if you like took some
serious hardcore drugs and played this
game oh my god oh god stop staring at me
you [ __ ]
you know everything oh my god this is
like the freakiest thing I've ever seen
in my entire life
oh yeah what am I going toward what why
he'll get away from nothing so obviously
if you didn't know I only can hello hi
who are you I help you boy please - wait
what oh something's being bulled at me
hang on here we go
look yeah look at that go holy crap that
actually worked wait Han I got this one
is dilution did I get it I'm not quite
get away from me I had no idea that the
oculus rift was combined like this it is
like the MA
it's the most I mean I know this is like
the lowest resolution version of the
oculus rift and like this isn't exactly
high fidelity gaming right here but I
mean still this is like it's freaking me
out
and how would you like me
they kind of come by my head and whoa
where'd you come from
those are freaky as hell see if I can
hit Mon come here give me some give me
some did okay yeah no gob what was that
oh that it's on a tree hang on wait a
minute okay everybody hold on a second
here yeah whoa
seriously they sit by my head in there I
actually get scared a little bit because
I get a little too close I'm not used to
the oculus rift in what is that that is
an elephant up there what is that
Oh oh that's a donut okay 600 oh oh oh
what's happening what's happening I'm
jumpy and floating holy crap I didn't
want to look down before this is pretty
key is hell what did what happened the
kid see something avid oh okay
that's a little disturbing okay what
happened this dumpy gonna be okay oh
yeah ha ha the game crashed I think did
that would happen I can barely see
that's the end of it at the end I want
to play more uh-oh it is freaky okay Han
okay well that was something that was
the coolest thing I've ever done in my
entire life
oh I'm looking here take care of that of
the that was uh those unbel I'll of the
oculus and this is this may be James
over here but I just got an email saying
that my oculus rift is gonna be
delivered within the next week so if
this is as cool do you like what you saw
here there's gonna be a lot more of this
because it was frickin amazing you have
got to try this if you get the chance so
anyway that's it for now a horror game
is coming up next so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
I know got no time okay where'd my
headphones go we're in the head don't go
hello there we go okay
don't like this okay about looking down
though it'll take Calabrese wait okay
there we go
I'm Peter I know okay so the graphics
are absolutely incredible